Hey guys, this is Joel with the Taproot Therapy Collective Podcast and now today we're going to do a meditation for a phobia or a specific piece of a trauma that you feel comfortable working with or maybe just an icky or bad realization or emotion that you have a hard time feeling and going through and that you want to work with your tolerance for and help resolve it and go through it and find all the roots of it in your body and your somatic associations and let all of those go. So before we start I want you to find a position that lets your body feel fully supported, seated or lying down. Make sure you're in a safe space to meditate, not driving, not
大家好，我是Taproot Therapy Collective播客的Joel。今天我们要进行一次冥想，针对你感到可以处理的某种恐惧症或创伤的特定部分，或者仅仅是你难以感受和经历、想要提高耐受力、帮助解决并理清其身体根源及躯体联想的某种令人不适的认知或情绪。在开始之前，请找一个让身体感到完全放松的姿势，坐着或躺着都可以。确保你处于一个安全的冥想空间，不要在开车，也不要
somewhere where you may be interrupted. And let your eyes gently close and take a few slow, deep breaths. And fully expand your belly on each inhale, completely releasing on each exhale. And with every breath, I want you to feel your body settling more deeply into a state of relaxed awareness and now bring to mind a specific phobia or fear or traumatic memory or just an energy that is hard to feel has an icky bad quality to it. And I want you to let it surface in your consciousness without any need to analyze or judge. Whenever a need to analyze or judge pops up, just notice that. And also notice an opposite part that is more open. And notice both parts. Come and go. And then notice how your body responds to this when you bring
在可能被打扰的地方。轻轻闭上眼睛，做几次缓慢的深呼吸。每次吸气时充分扩张腹部，呼气时彻底放松。随着每一次呼吸，感受你的身体更深地沉浸在一种放松的觉知状态中。现在，在脑海中浮现出一种特定的恐惧症、恐惧、创伤记忆，或者仅仅是一种难以感受、带有令人不适感的能量。让它浮现在你的意识中，无需分析或评判。每当想要分析或评判的念头出现时，只需注意到它。同时注意到与之相对的、更开放的部分。观察这两部分。来来去去。然后观察当你把
it into your mind. If you smell it, if you feel it in your skin or in the way that your body wants to react, if you hear something or if you just kind of remember it as a visual, go to the parts that are the harder parts to think about. If it's something you're afraid of doing in the future, make that real. If it's something that is from the past, revisit that. And notice how your body responds to this fear or aversion. And maybe you weren't able to find any of those pieces
它带入脑海时，你的身体有何反应。如果你闻到了它，如果你在皮肤上感受到了它，或者在身体想要反应的方式中感受到了它，如果你听到了什么，或者只是把它当作视觉记忆，那就去关注那些更难思考的部分。如果这是你未来害怕做的事情，让它变得真实。如果这是过去的事情，重温它。注意你的身体对这种恐惧或厌恶有何反应。也许你无法找到任何这些
of sensation and just treat it like an energy that you don't understand yet. If that's the case just feel it as an energy that is somewhere living in your body and I want you to find where that is and notice how it wants you to move and the sensations and memories it brings up. And then I want you to begin to trace that fear through your body and notice where you feel it the most intensely and map out every spot like you're charting a course for a trip to go from the beginning to the end and go ahead and finish this thing so it can be resolved. You may notice a knot in your stomach, a constriction in your
感觉的碎片，那就把它当作一种你还不理解的能量来对待。如果是这样，只需把它当作一种存在于你身体某处的能量来感受，找到它所在的位置，注意它想让你如何移动，以及它带来的感觉和记忆。然后，开始在你的身体中追踪这种恐惧，注意你在哪里感受得最强烈，像绘制旅行路线图一样标出每一个点，从起点到终点，完成这个过程，以便它能被解决。你可能会注意到胃部打结、
throat, a pressure in your chest, or more subtle sensations. Notice if your shoulders are pulling forward, your knees and thighs are pulling together. Maybe your hands are kind of rising up or clenching like they want to protect your heart. Maybe you feel like you want to disappear, run away, but I just want you to stay with those sensations and notice them and notice which one is strongest, which urge to move or part of somatic reaction or pain and imagine
喉咙紧缩、胸部压迫感，或其他更细微的感觉。注意你的肩膀是否向前收缩，膝盖和大腿是否并拢。也许你的手正在抬起或紧握，好像想要保护你的心脏。也许你觉得想要消失、逃跑，但我希望你保持这些感觉，注意它们，并观察哪一个最强烈，哪一种移动的冲动或躯体反应或疼痛最明显，想象
you can direct your breath into that area as if the breath is a soothing healing minty balm and picture the breath gently surrounding and permeating the sensation. On each breath in and each breath out let it form a cloud to protect you and create a little cushion of space and ease between you and the places that you're afraid to go and the things you're afraid to feel. And now I want you to let your imagination start to give you an image that captures or represents this fear or aversion. And it may be a vivid literal scene related to something you've witnessed or a more abstract symbolic representation and if it is a literal memory try and turn that into a mythic or metaphorical image like a painting or a little sketch
你可以将呼吸引导到那个区域，仿佛呼吸是一种舒缓、治愈的薄荷膏，想象呼吸轻轻地包围并渗透那种感觉。每一次吸气和呼气，让它形成一朵云来保护你，在你和你害怕去的地方、害怕感受的事物之间创造一个小小的缓冲空间和舒适感。现在，让你的想象力开始为你提供一个捕捉或代表这种恐惧或厌恶的意象。它可能是一个与你所见事物相关的生动写实场景，也可能是一个更抽象的象征性表现。如果是写实的记忆，试着把它变成一个神话或隐喻性的意象，比如一幅画或一个小草图
in your notebook maybe you're a mouse in a field hiding under grass that is too thin and there's a hawk above you or maybe you're in a closet and it's dark and you don't know if you can come out and you hear voices. But go to a place that will arise and trust that metaphor that you're making to be something that represents where you need to start in this moment on this journey. And take some time to
在你的笔记本上。也许你是一只躲在太稀疏的草丛下的田鼠，头顶有一只老鹰；或者你身处一个黑暗的壁橱里，不知道是否能出来，还能听到声音。去往那个浮现出的地方，相信你所创造的隐喻，它代表了你此刻在这段旅程中需要开始的地方。花点时间
really explore that inner landscape or memory and notice the sensations that you get in a carpet, smell, colors, textures, shapes, sounds, big sounds, little sounds, wind, temperature, humidity in the air. And if there are other figures in the scene beside yourself, observe their faces and their postures and their movements. If it's not a literal memory, explore this energy and feel all the parts of it and what it feels like it wants and where it feels like it wants to go. And the more you can immerse yourself in this symbolic world, the more insight and transformation that it's going to bring. And as you inhabit this inner environment, this space that you've created, this container, I want you to notice how it makes you feel in your whole body.
真正探索那个内在景观或记忆，注意你在地毯上感受到的感觉、气味、颜色、纹理、形状、声音、大声音、小声音、风、温度、空气中的湿度。如果场景中除了你之外还有其他人，观察他们的表情、姿势和动作。如果这不是写实的记忆，探索这种能量，感受它的所有部分，感受它想要什么，以及它想去哪里。你越能沉浸在这个象征性的世界中，它带来的洞察力和转化就越多。当你居住在这个内在环境中，这个你创造的空间，这个容器里，我希望你注意它让你整个身体有何感受。
Which sensations are stronger now than when we started? Which ones are softer? And where do you feel open and expansive and where do you feel tight and constrained? And let your somatic experience be your guide to the emotional heart of the image. And now begin to experiment with making experience be your guide to the emotional heart of the image and now begin to experiment with making small modifications to the scene. I want you to realize that you now have power over it, that it is inside of you and you are holding it and you're in the hands of your mind and start to change it. Start with something that is small and concrete.
哪些感觉比我们开始时更强烈？哪些更柔和？你在哪里感到开放和舒展，在哪里感到紧绷和受限？让你的躯体体验成为通往意象情感核心的向导。现在开始尝试对场景进行微小的修改。我希望你意识到你现在拥有对它的掌控力，它在你的内心，你掌控着它，你掌握在自己思想的手中，开始改变它。从微小而具体的事情开始。
If there's a shadowy figure in the distance, for instance, try gently brightening the light around the edges. If you're in a dark space, I want you to light a candle. And if you're in an enclosed space, see if you can open a window or a door just to crack even if you're scared And if it's a mythic image, I want you to make small changes that remind you of your power And your sense of control even if it's just moving a pedal I want you to change the image Just a little bit and if you're working with this as a more abstract energy notice how you can play with the energy slightly and move it around like water in a pan and make these changes very gradually one element at a time and observe closely how each shift impacts your embodied experience.
例如，如果远处有一个阴影，试着轻轻调亮边缘的光线。如果你在一个黑暗的空间里，点燃一支蜡烛。如果你在一个封闭的空间里，看看能否打开一扇窗户或一扇门，哪怕只是打开一条缝，即使你很害怕。如果这是一个神话意象，做出一些微小的改变，让你想起自己的力量和掌控感，哪怕只是移动一个花瓣。我希望你稍微改变一下意象。如果你把它当作一种更抽象的能量来处理，注意你如何能稍微摆弄这种能量，像平底锅里的水一样移动它。非常缓慢地进行这些改变，一次一个元素，并仔细观察每一次转变如何影响你的身体体验。
If you want to pause the meditation in order to have more time to play with this sense of control, you can do that now. As you change the image, you may notice a slight loosening of tension, a deepening of breath, a fleeting sense of possibility, but trust your intuition to guide these modifications. You might play with adjusting colors, shifting the size or the scale of objects, altering the speed or the rhythm of movement, slowing everything down to a stop, making sounds more quiet. Or you could introduce new sensory elements like a jacket or a warm coat, a blanket, a flashlight, a candle, or a soothing
如果你想暂停冥想以获得更多时间来体验这种掌控感，现在就可以这样做。当你改变意象时，你可能会注意到紧张感略微缓解，呼吸加深，一种转瞬即逝的可能性感，但要相信你的直觉来引导这些修改。你可以尝试调整颜色，改变物体的大小或比例，改变运动的速度或节奏，让一切慢下来直到停止，让声音变得更安静。或者你可以引入新的感官元素，比如一件夹克或一件暖和的外套、一条毯子、一个手电筒、一支蜡烛，或一种舒缓的
scent like jasmine or rosemary or lavender. Or you might experiment with your own position in the scene, moving yourself to a different vantage point or even stepping outside the scene altogether and observing it from a distance. And as you engage in this process of creative alteration, you may find some elements are more responsive to change than others. An unyielding surface might suddenly reveal a hidden doorway. A menacing figure might transform into a benevolent guide. A discordant sound might start to harmonize into a soothing melody and at the same time you may encounter resistance from certain parts of the image or from certain protective parts within yourself. If this happens, don't try and force the change.
气味，如茉莉、迷迭香或薰衣草。或者你可以尝试自己在场景中的位置，移动到一个不同的视角，甚至完全走出场景，从远处观察它。当你进行这种创造性改变的过程时，你可能会发现有些元素比其他元素更容易改变。一个坚硬的表面可能会突然显露出一扇隐藏的门。一个威胁性的形象可能会转变为一个仁慈的向导。一个不和谐的声音可能会开始协调成一段舒缓的旋律。同时，你可能会遇到来自意象某些部分或你内心某些保护性部分的阻力。如果发生这种情况，不要试图强行改变。
Simply acknowledge the resistance with respect and redirect your attention to an aspect of the scene that feels more malleable. Sometimes it helps to have a tool you can imagine that there is a paintbrush that you are swiping in front of your face and movement like moving your hand may help. You can smooth something away and cover it up and paint over it. Or lighting a scented candle or some burning sage as a tool may help change the scene. Or if you're having a hard time changing a physical sensation, open a drawer in front of you and take out what you need. And remember that this process is not about achieving a specific end,
只需尊重地承认这种阻力，并将注意力转向场景中感觉更具可塑性的方面。有时，拥有一个工具会有所帮助，你可以想象面前有一把画笔，像移动手一样在脸前挥动。你可以抹去某些东西，覆盖它，并在上面绘画。或者点燃一支香薰蜡烛或燃烧一些鼠尾草作为工具，可能有助于改变场景。或者，如果你在改变身体感觉方面遇到困难，打开面前的一个抽屉，取出你需要的东西。记住，这个过程不是为了达到特定的结果，
but about reconnecting to your innate capacity for flexible perception and creativity to solve your problem and the ability to have power over your past. And with each small modification, you're reminding your mind and body that you have the power to shape your experience in any given moment, not by denying your fear, but engaging with them in a spirit of curiosity and play even when they confront you, even when they scare you. And if you want to pause the meditation to play with several elements of your image,
而是为了重新连接你内在的灵活感知和创造力，以解决你的问题，并获得掌控过去的能力。通过每一次微小的修改，你都在提醒你的身心，你有能力在任何时刻塑造你的体验，不是通过否认你的恐惧，而是以好奇和玩耍的精神与它们互动，即使当它们面对你、吓唬你的时候。如果你想暂停冥想来摆弄意象中的几个元素，
you can do that now. And I'll continue exploring your inner landscape in a way for as long as it feels fruitful, making measured modifications, observing their impacts and honoring any resistance that arises with patience and with compassion and as you do so you may find that your original phobia begins to feel more workable, more fluid, less like an immutable truth and more like an imaginative story that can be revised and retold and as you feel your fears beginning to yield
现在就可以这样做。我会继续以一种感觉有成效的方式探索你的内在景观，进行适度的修改，观察它们的影响，并以耐心和同情心尊重任何出现的阻力。当你这样做时，你可能会发现你最初的恐惧症开始变得更易处理、更具流动性，不再像一个不可改变的事实，而更像一个可以被修改和重述的想象故事。当你感觉到你的恐惧开始屈服于
to this process of artful reshaping take a moment to reconnect with your breath and with your body and feel the ground beneath you steady and supportive and sense the expansiveness in your lungs, in your belly, the freedom in your limbs and in your digits. And notice how much more space there is in you than there is fear because you are vast and infinite and you have started to play with some of the multiplicity of the self. And when you feel ready to conclude this practice, I want you to take a deep and cleansing breath and slowly open your eyes and take a moment to reorient your surroundings, knowing that you can return to the center world of creativity
这个艺术化的重塑过程时，花点时间重新连接你的呼吸和身体，感受脚下稳固而支持你的地面，感受肺部、腹部的扩张感，四肢和手指的自由感。注意你内在的空间比恐惧要大得多，因为你是广阔而无限的，你已经开始玩味自我的多重性。当你准备好结束这次练习时，做一个深长的净化呼吸，慢慢睁开眼睛，花点时间重新适应周围的环境，知道你可以回到这个创造力的中心世界，
knowing that you can return to this inner world of creativity and imagination anytime you wish, that it's always inside of you. And then the days and the weeks to come, let your daily life become an ongoing extension of this practice. Whenever you feel the old fear arising, see if you can meet it with the same spirit of curiosity and play that you brought to your visualization and what might want to shift or reconfigure in your inner world in the same way the elements of your inner scene want to evolve? How might you experiment with small tweaks in your automatic or habitual response? Pausing where you'd normally react or choosing a new action where you would normally feel paralyzed. And as you start to live the insight that
知道你随时可以回到这个内在的创造力和想象力世界，它永远在你的内心。在接下来的日子和几周里，让你的日常生活成为这种练习的持续延伸。每当你感到旧的恐惧升起时，看看能否以你带入可视化练习中同样的探索和玩耍精神去面对它。你的内在世界中有什么想要转变或重构的，就像你内在场景中的元素想要演变一样？你如何尝试在自动或习惯性的反应中进行微小的调整？在通常会做出反应的地方停顿，或者在通常会感到瘫痪的地方选择一个新的行动。当你开始践行这一洞察，即
your reality is an endlessly creative construction constantly available for artful modification. Notice how the grip of your phobias begins to loosen little by little and let this growing sense of freedom fuel your commitment to the lifelong adventure of growth and of change. venture of growth and of change. And remember your fear served a purpose once, but it didn't need to define you forever and with every breath you have the chance to author a new story, one in which your trials become your triumphs and your wounds become your wisdom and your limitations, become your invitation to expand and to remember your expansiveness and may you come to know yourself as the creative master of your own experience now and always.
你的现实是一个无穷无尽的创造性构建，随时可以进行艺术化的修改。注意你的恐惧症的束缚是如何一点一点开始松动的，让这种日益增长的自由感推动你对成长和改变的终身冒险的承诺。记住，你的恐惧曾经发挥过作用，但它不需要永远定义你。每一次呼吸，你都有机会创作一个新的故事，在这个故事中，你的磨难成为你的胜利，你的伤口成为你的智慧，你的局限成为你扩展和记住自身广阔性的邀请。愿你现在并永远认识到自己是自身体验的创造性主人。
And may every challenge become an opportunity to deepen your faith in your own endless resilience and ingenuity and endless capacity for transformation. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
愿每一个挑战都成为加深你对自己无穷韧性、创造力以及无限转化能力的信念的机会。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。